hi i'm benedict cumberbatch and this is
your weekend ticket million theaters
this weekend dr. Seuss is the Grinch the
girl in the spider's web a new Dragon
Tattoo story and overlords what will you
see this is your weekend ticket ah The
Grinch returns from Mount crumpet yet
again for another anti Christmas protest
this time voiced by the charming
Benedict Cumberbatch look at those
greedy little kiss monsters ready this
3d computer-animated comedy is the third
time this dr. Seuss character is seen
screen time the first being the 1966
animated TV special and of course the
2000 live-action Jim Carrey feature How
the Grinch Stole Christmas this movies
for you if you like any of the
variations of the Grinch story you're
looking for a great family film to get
you in the route for the holidays or you
like your Grinch like you like your eggs
Benedict's also out this weekend the
girl and the spider's web a new Dragon
Tattoo story this equal to David
Fincher's Girl with the Dragon Tattoo is
actually a soft reboot with new actors
portraying the characters of the film
Claire Foy is now playing Elizabeth
Salander whose mission is to save and
avenge battered women he won't talk to
again there's also computer hackers
spies corruption and cyber criminals fun
this movies for you if you liked the
crime thriller genre you're a fan of the
millennium novel series titles or if you
have a tattoo of a dragon in a spider's
web I know it's rare I know you're out
there
and finally overlord hits theaters this
week Overlord is a world war 2 horror
movie that follows American paratroopers
in a battle on the day before d-day near
Normandy France after their plane gets
shot down they discovered Nazis aren't
the only enemy they're fighting secret
Nazi experiments have developed
grotesque and aggressive creature things
that are gross and mean
this one is for you if you like
fantastical in fictional war stories or
you're a fan of other JJ Abrams produced
movies like Star Trek Armageddon or
Cloverfield
that is your weekend ticket what will
you see check back next week for some
Marky Mark getting a new Funky Bunch
some of you kids don't get that
[Music]